In honor of my roots and today's discourse I imitate it in Spanish,
the language with the largest number of native speakers.
in the world.
Five hundred years ago,
the encounter and clash of civilizations
accelerated through an accelerated process of conquest,
colonization,
exploitation and domination.
Simón Bolívar,
the liberator of South America in Venezuela,
to have climbed to a summit,
that of Chimborazo,
and there,
on the eternal slopes of the Andes mountain range,
imagined to have entered with time an old gentleman with a long beard and
very wise And time ordered Bolívar after a dialogue at that summit said to
him "go and tell the truth to men today allow me to come here as the
standard bearer of that Bolivarian dream to cry out to nations to the
world Let us tell the truth to men on behalf of the Bolivarian people And
it is a cry to humanity The time has come Let's
save the world brother 1,000 thanks.